i saw on your wikipedia you have a movie
credit called
laid in america what a fantastic [ __ ]
name and
what's that about oh wait
have you ever been made in america uh i
actually have yeah yeah
of course of course come on but um yeah
no it was just uh
an experience but we you know me and
caspar lee
i don't know if you know caspar lee but
we made
uh worked on this movie back in the day
i think in 2014
2015 and uh we just thought would be a
funny idea we um
is essentially two uh foreign exchange
students
and we had one more day left before we
went back to our country so
we were like [ __ ] we're both virgins
we need to [ __ ] that's just
so it's literally us just trying to get
laid in america in this final day
and it's just i mean i don't know it's
it could some people see it as a classic
where can they see it uh it's just
everywhere like it's
like online was it a profitable venture
i imagine it's
coming 2014 2014 2015 those were big
years for you so i gotta imagine that
that brought in some dough
i don't think i actually remember me
getting any money
so that was like what was the budget for
the film and who made it
uh i think the budget was about a mill
and um
it's uh these two guys who made it i've
forgotten their names now
but um yeah they were they were pretty
cool like
um i should remember their names i think
one of them was peter
and the other was i forgotten but yeah
they were they were just really cool and
yeah they were just came up to us with
this idea and we're like yeah [ __ ] it
let's do it
i think they would prefer you remember
the name of the movie and to
tell people about the movie then their
names yeah
i'm gonna watch that [ __ ] laid in
america please don't
yeah dude